und auf dauer aus der schule plaudern
kann auch die mehrfach preisgekrönte
schriftstellerin ruth schweikert einer
der wichtigen metallischen stimmen der
schweiz ist hier am institut als
mentorin fertig und erzählt uns jetzt
über diese fast schon im team
aufgenommen
arno camenisch melancholischen mich ein
für michelle stein weg alle erfolgreich
heute und einst studis von gut 2 kann
sie hilft beim suchen nach stillen und
stoffen versteht das schweizerische
literaturinstitut als labor heraus sagen
wo ja wo cruise aufzieht und rominger
und ist dafür dass junge menschen wo sie
sagen liebe hat der wichtigen
stellenwert im land auf handfeste seit
zehn jahren führt sie ihre schützlinge
hin zum literarischen erfolg einer der
gefeierten der bieler talentschmiede
demo kamin geradelt mit dem schweizer
literaturpreis sei ein typischer
vertreter des hauses zugestanden hätte
während dem studium eigentlich das erste
buch publiziert oder oder oder
das sehr stark leitet seit er hat uns
wirklich entwickelt das machen kann
viele dinge ist besser these also was
man die frühjahr statt
denn überhaupt erst wenn aus diesen erst
lingen erfolge werden dann hat man
vorher die betreuung gestimmt das heißt
intensives eins zu eins kopie in biel
nennt sich das nennt oder hat
das team vom tech support von einer idee
von einer wohnt führt von einer
vorstellung und unten darf begleitet der
austausch zwischen den studierenden und
zwischen den kulturen diesen austausch
als bereicherung begleiten
ein wichtiger bestandteil der ausbildung
zum integrierte ruth schweikert die
arbeit von marco lüssi bei der im kosovo
geborenen autorin ging es darum zweifel
abzubauen
bei deutsch nicht ihre muttersprache ist
aber die sprache in der sie schreckt
nicht komplett beherrschen der sprache
fruchtbar machen gesellschaftliche
realitäten bekannten geschichten
das hat dezent in schwaig hat ihre
studenten koreanischen richtig gut
eingebracht so gut dass diese genau wie
sie selbst im jahr 2015 für den
schweizer buchpreis nominiert wurde
[Musik]